which brings us to an almost entirely
different
political issue right now so war in
Ukraine which is really a proxy war
between Russia which invaded Ukraine and
America which has tried to deepen ties
to Ukraine and has encouraged Ukraine to
apply for membership in the European
Union and turn toward NATO for
protection and has has tried to oust
some of the more pro-russian leaders of
that country now you've got a proxy war
in what was once a buffer state
well Vladimir Putin has just raised the
stakes of the war because he's choosing
not to
continue along with a major nuclear
treaty this is the new start treaty he's
saying that he's going to suspend the
new start treaty doesn't really Bode
very well for the war and in a speech in
which he lambasted the West he attacked
the West specifically for the woke virus
that it is spreading around the world
that that Vladimir Putin says is
threatening
the children of non-western States
Russian children and and other places
where the culture hasn't totally seeped
in I'll I'll translate the speech not
not from Russian but I'll read the
subtitles while he speaks
and theater they lie constantly perverts
historical facts do not stop attacks on
our culture
and other traditional religious
organizations of our country see what
they do with their own peoples this is
in the west the destruction of the
family cultural the national identity
of children
the norm of their life and Priests are
forced to bless same-sex marriages
god with them let them do what they want
what do I want to say here I don't have
the right to live as they want we have
always thought like this in Russia and
we always will first of all what are you
kidding me no one will invade private
lives we are not going to do this I know
we were Communists for like a hundred
years but forget about that
but I want to tell them look at the holy
scriptures the main books of all other
world religions everything is said there
including that the family is the union
of a man in the world
[Applause]
legislators what these sacred texts
it became known the Anglican Church for
example plans to consider the idea of a
gender neutral God the Russian accent is
getting the worst this goes along
what can we say
forgive us Lord they know not what they
do
millions of people in the west
understand that they are leading to a
real spiritual disaster the elites
directly I must say go crazy and it
seems that they can no longer be treated
show me the LIE there but these are
their problems as I said and we must
protect our children and we will do this
protect our children from degradation
and degeneration I talked on the show
yesterday about
the the most important aspect of good
propaganda
and coincidentally now we're seeing
Vladimir Putin who's an excellent
propagandist exercise this good
propaganda
is the kind that's true
and even if it's not a hundred percent
true it's got a lot of truth to it there
are a lot of things that Vladimir Putin
is suggesting here that are not true
he's suggesting that in the west the
church blames blesses rather same-sex
marriage that isn't true that is true in
some of the Protestant churches though
it's not true in the Catholic Church
which is the Church of the West for 2000
years but it's true in some Protestant
churches there's a there's a fair bit of
Truth to that
it's true that in the west now the West
doesn't really respect many aspects of
private life now of course Russia was
the Communist Empire for much of the
20th century so I don't want to hear Too
Many lectures about respecting private
life from Vladimir Putin okay but he's
right about what he's saying about the
West in many ways he's saying that in
the west there are policies encouraging
the destruction of the family that's
true Russia has not been very successful
at promoting The Rebirth of the family
but they have taken certain State
measures to turn around their birth rate
problem and encourage the family
it's true no Russia has a lot of other
problems than that they allow all sorts
of pornography and they promote I think
they even promote sort of underage
pornography and all sorts of abusive
terrible stuff but what they're saying
about the West
there's a lot of truth to it the
degeneration the degradation that's
being pushed in the west that's a
problem he's saying we're going to
protect our kids from that that's the
kind of message that is going to
resonate that's very very good
propaganda and you can say well Vladimir
Putin you're misrepresenting your
country well Vladimir Putin you're misre
representing your War aims well Vladimir
Putin you're you're a meanie and you're
a terrible guy you can say all that that
can all be true
but much if not most of what he is
accusing the west of doing is true what
are we going to do about it if we want
Vladimir Putin to have less effective
propaganda we should probably
we should probably stop encouraging the
conditions that allow a lot of that
propaganda to be true
speaking of the war in Ukraine
a major
incident in the presidential race in
2024 that a lot of people aren't talking
about it's not that there's a new
candidate though there is a new
candidate we'll get to that in a second
probably the the biggest change in the
2024 race is that we have now I think
for the first time gotten a foreign
policy statement from the chief
Republican rival to Donald Trump Ron
DeSantis here's what Ron DeSantis thinks
about the war in Ukraine
they have effectively a blank check
policy with no clear strategic objective
identified and these things can can
escalate and I don't think it's in our
interest to be getting into proxy war
with China getting involved over things
like the Borderlands or over Crimea so I
think it would behoove them to identify
what is the Strategic objective that
they're trying to to achieve but just
saying it's an open-ended blank check
that is not acceptable so Governor what
does a win look like for us in Ukraine
for Ukraine
well I think it's important to point out
I mean you know the fear of kind of
Russia going into NATO countries and all
that and steamrolling you know that has
not even come close to happening I think
they've shown themselves to be a
third-rate military power I think
they've suffered tremendous tremendous
losses I got to think that the people in
Russia are probably disapproving of
what's going on I don't think they can
speak up about it for obvious reasons so
I think Russia has been really really
wounded here and I don't think that they
are the same threat to our country even
though they're hostile I don't think
they're on the same level as a China
this is a masterful answer from Ron
DeSantis because don't forget Donald
Trump's greatest strength in the
president presidential race today is
probably his foreign policy
it was the most different from the other
Republican rivals in 2016 and from
probably most other Republican
politicians today
and it's the most effective foreign
policy we've seen certainly in my
lifetime
it's the most effective foreign policy
certainly since George H.W bush maybe
since Ronald Reagan
because Donald Trump was unpredictable
the bad guys were not nearly as
aggressive on Donald Trump's watch as
they have been on the watch of other
presidents Donald Trump scored major
foreign policy wins Donald Trump brought
a fair degree of peace to the Middle
East which people probably would not
have guessed when when he was first
elected but he has a very strong foreign
policy record
and the GOP base is torn right now
between the
the really bullish pro-war go in glass
Russia take over Ukraine's side which is
not as represented among the base but
the GOP Elites really like that idea and
then the base and the more paleo
conservative and the more isolationist
side which says why are we focused on
Kiev when we've got a chemical spill in
East Palestine Ohio people can't drink
the water in their town but we're
focused on giving pensions to ukrainians
for what give me a break
and then you've got the more hawkish
side in the GOP saying no if we don't go
in and take over Ukraine uh Vladimir
Adolf Putin is going to conquer all of
Europe he's not only the next Hitler
he's the next Napoleon he's the next
he's the next Genghis Khan we have to
stop him now and and how does Ron
DeSantis handle this
he says
the threat from Russia has been
exaggerated there is not evidence that
Russia is going to steamroll into Poland
or Hungary or other places in the West
yeah
Russia's been degraded Russia has been
revealed to be not a very strong nuclear
not a very strong military power they
are a nuclear power so there is still
some threat there it's a very good
answer it's a very good answer for Ron
DeSantis we'll see
how that keeps up talk is cheap of
course and Trump has the advantage of
having had an actual foreign policy it's
not desantis's fault Florida just
doesn't have a foreign policy we will
see now how consistent Rhonda Santos can
be in his foreign policy uh rest of the
show starts now you don't want to miss
it go to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign